we are with
grandmaster wesley so after a draw today
again sam shanklin wesley it seemed like
you had a pleasant position coming out
the opening with some chances uh what
happened
yeah i messed it up real quick
that's basically what happened uh it's
just not been
not been my day i think uh
yeah i've been playing well the last
couple days uh
i think sam also had not an ideal
tournament but basically i just played
badly today that's what happened and uh
i i'm not exactly sure how big my
advantage was but i think was pretty
good but
or i could be wrong and i might just be
slightly better but i thought i had a
dominant position
it's just not easy to to make progress
and
in the end i made a few inaccuracies and
i thought the final position was just
equal so i made a repetition
uh this
puts you in second place behind maxine
vashila grav
and you have a big game tomorrow against
that same player your thoughts
yeah i mean maxim has been on fire in
this tournament winning four games
losing one uh he's playing really well
he won the croatia
also so i kind of expected that he would
bounce back at some point after his
bad tournaments in like candidates and
in romania so
it's clear he's one of the best players
in the world and he's on on fire
recently so i'm gonna have to fight hard
uh tomorrow but i i
i'm not sure
how he managed to bounce back so easily
because he's been playing non-stop also
he played in the world cup
then he flew here
uh maybe he had some some rest while we
were playing the rapid end blitz but
he's playing really really well
that's a big point is
rest over
practice
uh which one would you normally take
yeah i i follow michael bought vinick's
advice correct me answer if i'm wrong
but i think he mentioned that a
professional player should spend half
their time resting and preparing and
then half their time playing so that's
the ideal work life balance situation
so that's why i skipped the world cup uh
also because of kovid reasons
but i thought i made a pretty good
choice of skipping the world cup all the
guys like maxim and sam they played
and it seems maxim has a lot of energy
but
but maybe he's prepared hard for this
event
because you mentioned he didn't play as
saint louis rapping in blitz so yeah he
was able to watch you guys while you you
kind of punched each other out yeah also
he's been in st louis uh he came early
like two weeks early or ten days early
right so
yeah he doesn't have deadline all that
he was able to rest and recover
and uh i i think that's helped him a lot
i'm sure he did a lot of training coming
in
i'm hearing you give a lot of pluses to
mvl
what are you going to do
to get that out your head so you can be
successful tomorrow uh
uh well i i think
uh some games in this tournament have
not been ideal uh like like today
overall i'm playing decently
but i i just need to to rest and recover
and and give my best give my best chest
tomorrow i did a lot of preparation for
this tournament but there comes a point
where rest is more important than
preparation and i think we've reached
uh that stage
well we'll let you go prepare to rest
thank god good luck tomorrow yeah thank
you that's also one of the reasons why i
repeated moves
i can rest early
thank you thank you thank you wesleyan
very good luck tomorrow as that is going
to be
well all an important game